my name is Li dire I've been teaching
human resource management at Cornell
University for 45 years I've seen a lot
of change in that time but none more
profound or more important than the
changes that lie ahead over the next few
years major transformations will be
taking place in the nature of work and
it will be up to each of us to decide
how these will unfold and to make sure
that they work out the way we want them
to be as this figure shows HR
professionals will be right square in
the middle of things ultimately it is
the human resource strategies that
organizations enact which play a major
role in determining how many jobs are
created as well as the quality of these
jobs but of course HR professionals
don't operate in a vacuum a number of
forces global competition emerging
technological developments societal
pressures and labor market conditions
influence firms business strategies and
in turn their human resource strategies
and there are a number of key players in
the process as well
these include labor organizations of
various types public policymakers who
make and enforce the rules of the game
and educators who are responsible for
helping folks develop the skills they
need to succeed the challenge for HR
professionals is to understand the
environmental forces at work and to work
with the key players to develop desired
results and of course this means doing
all they can to be sure that their
organizations have enough high-quality
people to do the work that needs doing
but it also means striving to ensure
that everyone who wants to work is able
to get a job and not just any job but
one that provides both a decent standard
of living and a sense of personal
fulfillment and a
this is where our course comes in you
will learn how the important external
forces globalization technology and so
forth have changed over time and are
expected to change in the years ahead
you also will learn what can be expected
of key players in the process labor
organizations public policymakers and so
forth in the coming years and how you
can work with them to forge mutually
acceptable agreements on key issues in
short if you are or are aspiring to be
an HR professional or manager completion
of this course will help position you to
influence the nature of the changes that
will be taking place in the years ahead
both in the US and around the world